تخيل عندما كنت طفلاً كنت تعتقد أنه إذا كان بإمكانك
الحصول على ما يكفي من
بالونات الشفاء ، فهل يمكنك أن تطفو بعيدًا
، وعادةً ما نقول لا ، هذا غير
ممكن أنك لن تكون قادرًا على
الطيران
بالونات شفاء ولكني أعدت النظر في هذه
الفكرة كشخص بالغ و
لقد جادلت إذا كان أحد البالونات يوفر بعضًا
من وحدة الرفع ،
فلماذا لا نتمكن من توسيع نطاق
ذلك وهذا ما نفعله
[موسيقى]
أنا أطير مقعدي
[موسيقى] ،
اسمي تراب وأنا مدير مشروعات تقني
في منتدى استشاري كبير لتكنولوجيا المعلومات كعمل يومي ،
لكن
لدي هواية شغوفة غير عادية
وهي أخذ بالونات الهيليوم لتلعب
بالونات الهيليوم وتجميعها في
مجموعات ضخمة للطيران المأهول ،
هذه بالونات لم يكن
الغرض منها أبدًا دعم رحلة مأهولة ولكن
هذا ما نحن عليه  لقد جعلتهم يقومون بـ
17100 لا يزالون أتسلق هذا الشغف
الذي حملني عالياً في
أكثر من اثنتي عشرة رحلة جوية عبر عدة
سنوات
أحيانًا يكون جسدي فقط في
أحزمة صغيرة جدًا أحيانًا نطير
بأشياء أكبر لقد قمت بالطيران
يا له من شيء أقوله ، لقد طرت منازل
اثنين منهم
كنا نطير بالونات الهيليوم هذه
قبل فيلم ديزني بيكسار ، لكنني
سأقول أن الفيلم
ألهمنا أيضًا الآن فكرة
الطيران في منزل
تحت لعبة بالونات الهيليوم  لقد
أتت تمامًا من فيلم disney pixar ،
أحد الأشياء التي أحبها في تحليق
بالونات الهيليوم هذه هو أنها تتمتع
بالقدرة على
رحلات طيران على مستوى الرحلات الاستكشافية الحقيقية ، ما
أتحدث عنه هو الرحلات الجوية التي
يبلغ ارتفاعها 23000 قدم في جندول مفتوح
تحمله بالونات الهيليوم فقط ثلاثة عشر
على بعد ألف قدم ونحن نعبر جبال الألب
، يختلف الأمر من مجموعة صغيرة إلى
دزينة من البالونات
إلى مجموعات شاهقة كبيرة جدًا.
رحلة واحدة
466 ميلاً عندما أقلع ، لا أعرف إلى
أين سأقوم باختيار
مكان آمن للهبوط في الرحلة
لكني أطير مئات الأميال دون أن
أعرف بالضبط
أين سأهبط
[  م  usic]
نحن جيدون ، فنحن محبطون
لذا فهو مزيج من الفن والعلم ، والفن
هو المجموعة الملونة من
بالونات الشفاء ولكن العلم
هو أنه خطير للغاية وأنا أتعامل معه
بجدية ، فهناك حياة بشرية على المحك وحياتي
وحياتي  من هؤلاء الذين أشاركهم
السماء وحياة من هم تحت لي ،
مرحباً ، كيف حالك
نحن نعمل مع إدارة الطيران الفيدرالية
فيما يتعلق بالحصول على
شهادة الطائرات في
لندن ، هذا منطاد غاز
لتفعيل خطة رحلتي ،
لقد استغرق الأمر حوالي عام حتى  اذهب إلى
مدرسة الطيران واحصل على رخصة طيار وبعد
حوالي عام من الاختبارات والتدريب والشهادات ،
لقد قمنا بأول رحلة لنا باستخدام
كرسي مكتبي القياسي كجندول لتلك
الرحلة عندما تكون هناك ليس
فقط الترفيه والاسترخاء.  إعادة
الطفو بعيدًا لديك
لحظات من ذلك ، ولكن هناك الكثير من
الوقت الذي أمضيته في التفكير ،
حسنًا ، هل أنا أسير في الاتجاه الصحيح ، هل
لدي أي مجال جوي أو عوائق
أمامي ،
حسنًا ، نحن نتسلق 120 على
ارتفاع 18000 قدم ، لذلك أنا  نحاول جعل هذا الرجل في وضع
ضغط صفري ،
عليك أن تطير بالطائرة إذا
كنت أتسلق وأحتاج إلى بدء
الهبوط ، أحتاج إلى تنفيس
الهيليوم ، فإن البالونات قابلة للتحلل حتى
نتمكن أيضًا من قطع البالونات
بعيدًا عن
البالونات الفردية  لذلك ، هناك عملية حسابية كاملة
وتغير كل رحلة
اعتمادًا على ما
أطير به [موسيقى] ، الشعور بالانطلاق لا مثيل له ، فليس مثل أي شيء آخر أن تطير
طائرة صامتة تمامًا
لا تصدر أي صوت نقترب من غروب الشمس ،
إنه أمر رائع حقًا
لا يوجد دوار لا يوجد
دعامة
ولا نفاثة ولا موقد مثل
منطاد الهواء الساخن ولا يوجد هدير للرياح
مثلما تدخل في طائرة شراعية
إنه صامت تمامًا مثل الاستماع
لا يوجد صوت لذا ما هو
الهدف من هذا كله
لماذا تفعل ذلك لقيادة  حياة
ممتعة هي أجمل صعود للقمر
رأيته في حياتي كلها ،
فهي تثري حياتي لأنظر إلى الوراء
والتفكير في ما أنجزناه
[تصفيق]
لدي كل  تلك اللحظات هي
ذكريات
ثمينة تجعلني أشعر بالدفء في شيخوختي